[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález costa rica
cumplió dos semanas de protestas de
grupos sociales y de grupos sindicales
en rechazo a un eventual acuerdo
financiero de ese país con el fondo
monetario internacional y también debido
a un incremento de los impuestos que
propone también el presidente alvarado
pero se espera que para los próximos
días se establezca una mesa de dialogo
algo que ya fue completamente descartado
por las partes que deberían haberse
sentado allí a negociar y que debía
comenzar el próximo fin de semana una
mesa que buscaba la concertación que
buscaba un acuerdo para que beneficiar a
ambas partes y empezará a reducirse a
estas manifestaciones a nivel ciudadano
a esto hay que añadirle también un
malestar precisamente de los
costarricenses los ciudadanos por el mal
momento económico que está atravesando
este país debido a la pandemia del cobi
19 los números no son alentadores veamos
la contracción de la economía de costa
rica- lleva al 5.5 por ciento del
desempleo ya ronda
4.4 por ciento y el crecimiento estimado
del pib para el 2021 será del 2.1 por
ciento mientras que el endeudamiento
para el próximo año el 2021 será del 70
y 4.8 por ciento del pib
para hacer frente a esta situación
desatada por la crisis de el coronavirus
el gobierno del presidente carlos
alvarado ha buscado ayuda en los
mercados internacionales como una manera
para poder hacer frente a esta situación
el gobierno de costa rica buscaba porque
ya lo descartó acceder a un crédito del
fondo monetariointernacional por mil 750
millones de dólares en un periodo de
tres años este fue el detonante de las
manifestaciones por lo que no le gustó a
diferentes sectores y salieron a las
calles de ese país para decirle no
queremos este tipo de acuerdo también al
principio de la pandemia costa rica fue
aplaudido a nivel internacional por el
manejo que le estaban dando a la crisis
pero pues porque estaban presentando muy
pocos casos de contagio pero la
situación de repente empezó a cambiar y
ahora el contagio avanza rápidamente y
las autoridades están intentando hacer
frente a esta situación así es como
están las cosas hasta el día de hoy
costa rica registra 91 mil 780 casos de
contagio mientras que las víctimas
mortales ya llegan a 1.134 estas son
cifras que publican la universidad
johns hopkins en su conteo a nivel
mundial
para analizar este tema y resolver todas
las dudas que tenemos en torno a la
situación en costa rica hemos invitado a
saray esquivel presidente o presidenta
de la asociación de profesores enseñanza
apse e institución que estaría en esa
supuesta mesa de diálogo con el gobierno
nacional nos atiende desde la ciudad de
san josé y también desde la capital
costarricense hasta con nosotros eugenia
aguirre jazz politóloga e investigadora
del observatorio de la política nacional
de la universidad de costa rica ustedes
también pueden ser parte de este debate
deje sus comentarios en las redes
sociales no se encuentra como france24
s arroba sant y luego la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 pues tenemos el
contexto tenemos a las invitadas y
tenemos ya las preguntas para comenzar
con ellas y comienzo entonces con saray
preguntándole por la noticia que llega
el día de hoy a nivel mundial y es
porque se rompe esta posibilidad de una
mesa de diálogo para empezar a concertar
entre las partes después de estas dos
semanas de manifestaciones
bueno buenas noches un saludo cordial a
todos y no agradecimiento
bueno si nos venimos dando hace cuentas
un ratito de la situación de que las
condiciones no estaban para que el
diálogo se desarrollara
y algunos algunas organizaciones
estábamos
y preocupadas porque las condiciones o
los requisitos que se estaban pidiendo
para realizar esta mesa de diálogo pues
no nos parecían sentíamos que irán
un poco una organización sindical
tenemos
por eso a sentir adquisiciones tennant
ese destino
consultadas
entonces la digamos en este momento el
gobierno lo que está diciendo es que
solamente decía que organizaciones o
grupos
este 2 estaba pero todavía no ha
manifestado
y más que todo porque esto fue como muy
rápido y el domingo a la noche
espacio el lunes amanecimos ya apareció
un documento con los requisitos y
y todo este análisis de la posibilidad
pues
nos llevamos todo este proceso nosotros
en el caso de nosotros como organización
tenemos en medio una manifestación que
se realizó desde el día de ayer entonces
y algo así como un poco día aunque
queríamos aunque queremos porque es una
cuestión que todas queríamos el diálogo
y un poco sobre las condiciones
quiero preguntarle acera y entonces no
está descartada esta mesa de diálogo
simplemente digamos que está pospuesta y
en unos días podríamos estar hablando
que el gobierno se siente con los
diferentes sectores a conversar
perfecto eugenia quiero preguntarle por
el contexto y por la situación que vive
costa rica como en la aceptación del
presidente alvarado allí en este país su
gestión porque esta posibilidad de hacer
una negociación con el fmi despierta en
estas estas manifestaciones ciudadanas y
lleva a cientos de personas a las calles
hubo bloqueos de las carreteras bloqueos
de las principales vías del centro de
san jose e incluso manifestaciones que
fueron bastante agresivas frente a la
residencia o al palacio presidencial que
es lo que se estaba viviendo allí
bueno noche santiago ya todas las
personas que sintonizan a través del
debate de france 24 tenemos que recordar
que esto es un gobierno que llega con
uno de los índices de popularidad más
bajos en la historia de que se lleva
este conteo por distintos estudios de
opinión no gozó este gobierno de lo que
normalmente conocemos como la luna de
miel después de la elección
y los primeros días o inclusive años en
que ejercen el poder y esto tiene que
ver también con la naturaleza al proceso
electoral que este gobierno logra llegar
a esta segunda ronda que vivimos en 2018
con un apoyo muy limitado y buscando
alianzas en otros en partidos
tradicionales como es el caso del
partido unidad social cristiana el
durante la gestión de la pandemia el
presidente alvarado y su equipo vio un
repunte muy importante que el centro de
investigación y estudios políticos y la
universidad de costa rica calificó como
un rally around the flag o un rally
alrededor de la bandera apoyando estos
primeros meses que como nos viene
explicadas de la gestión de la pandemia
fue muy exitosa
pero una vez pasado este primer ciclo
volvimos a los niveles normales de
popularidad de este gobierno que se
relacionan con una conformación
multipartidaria que ha perdido
importantes figuras más de 14 ministros
y ministros del gabinete se han retirado
que empieza una fase debilitamiento de
su conformación y agravada
particularmente por la dificultad de
concertar un equipo económico con una
propuesta sólida en la materia y que en
tiempos de pandemia pues se hace
muchísimo más necesario en una especie
de hastío y desconfianza respecto a las
vías de diálogo que el gobierno ha
planteado para atender las soluciones a
esta crisis
sara y usted es presidenta de una
asociación en particular usted ya nos
explicaba algunos de los puntos de esta
posible mesa de diálogo porque el
rechazo a estas propuestas que hace el
gobierno para poder hacer frente a la
difícil situación que está viviendo
costa rica hay que entender el contexto
en el que estamos a nivel mundial esta
pandemia no es el único país que está
teniendo problemas económicos porque el
rechazo a estas propuestas
bueno hay que conocer
primero un poco más atrás lo que está
sucediendo desde el punto de vista de
nosotros como organización sindical y la
situación pues que se detona ya a nivel
de país
primero nosotros venimos saliendo de un
proceso con
de enfrentar cambios el port de proyecto
de ley que quieren hacer es reformar
cristales y nosotros tuvimos de aguacate
de meses este y a raíz de este
movimiento también no una
y una ley en contra de ellas
cambiando las condiciones para realizar
huelgas en el país entonces fueron dos
procesos muy difíciles en contra de toda
esta situación de todas estas propuestas
muy liberales y eso hace que ésta esté
mal o están bien arrastrado desde antes
en el caso de nosotros nosotros
organizaciones sindicales y algunos
grupos sociales que como en pocos en
este momento entonces es que eso viene
arrastrándose y entramos
en este año gente con una situación de
aplicación de las reformas fiscales
porque esa vuelta desde el punto de
vista
[Música]
para empezar
entonces pues tienen sus consecuencias y
en el salario y en las condiciones
laborales y salariales
se publicó inmediatamente después de
esto entramos a la famosa pandemia
19 eso ya me enero que entonces por las
condiciones en el país como decía vivir
la compañera es que también cambien
radicalmente de ese problema fiscal que
tiene este país se agudizó con la
pandemia
y entramos en donde se tenía que decidir
quién iba a aportar más para que ésta
para que se puedan enfrentar a toda la
situación que se está dando como los
datos que usted al inicio con respecto
al desempleo de todas las cosas si
entonces éste eso hace que él
que estallan roces como dijo la
politóloga esté ahí no hay buen ambiente
para el presidente se crea se ha creado
mucha falta de credibilidad en lo que se
procede desde entonces todo esto ha
generado desconfianza y por eso
cuando se propone está primero al
mediador que se está dando para para
este proceso no hay que lidiar tampoco
entonces en el caso de nosotros
específicamente hay
en las condiciones se nos dice por
ejemplo que esté si en algún punto no
hay acuerdo el gobierno va a ser el que
defina de la puerta
en otro punto por ejemplo que si no se
no se permite la consulta a las bases
que es algo que como organización
y eugenia y seguimos haciendo el
análisis y tratando de entender esta
situación
en costa rica pongamos un poco más en
contexto cómo ha sido en este país
centroamericano que no es un país
parecido al del resto de la región por
eso la importancia llama la atención a
este tipo de manifestaciones y este tipo
de debate que se está dando allí entre
la sociedad los sindicatos y el gobierno
como en la relación histórica que ha
tenido el gobierno el estado
costarricense con los sectores
sindicales y con estos movimientos
ciudadanos a lo largo de los últimos
años
gracias por la pregunta costa rica se
han brotado por el diálogo para atender
los puentes y tomar los acuerdos al
respecto de cómo dirigir asuntos
públicos de inclusión la
institucionalidad y diseña dos espacios
muy importantes de encuentro entre los
sectores sindicales y el sector privado
con el estado y con el ministerio de
trabajo inclusive y es una relación que
como bien explica doña sara se ha
tensado a propósito de los
acontecimientos más recientes y quiero
recapitular algunas de las propuestas
que se enquistó a partir de la de la
reforma fiscal de 2018 tramitan 2018 y
que de alguna manera agota el capital
político del gobierno 90 días de huelga
histórica en el seguimiento que hacemos
de las huelgas desde los distintos
centros de investigación
se aprueba se logra implantar la la
reforma que entre las medidas más
importantes se instaura el impuesto al
valor agregado tanto sobre bienes como
servicios y apenas empezando a recuperar
la economía del país la pandemia viene
azotar de manera importante los logros y
las expectativas que se tenían en torno
a la reforma fiscal aquí es fundamental
en este relacionamiento y mucho también
de lo que desde el observatorio la
política nacional hemos llamado el
origen de esta disputa tan compleja
tiene que ver con las formas en que el
gobierno ha intentado establecer este
diálogo y los errores y las
contradicciones por ejemplo en la
conformación de un consejo económico y
social que al día de hoy es un papel no
ha sido debidamente conformado
la propuesta estrella que en su momento
iba a ser la base del acuerdo con el
fondo monetario internacional una
propuesta virtual de diálogo costa rica
propone escucha y dialoga no sé no fue
suficiente para tener acuerdos de manera
que cuando la propuesta con el fondo
monetario internacional saliera a la luz
pública fuera apoyada por los sectores y
ahora este último intento que es un
intento donde se suma además el
liderazgo del presidente de la asamblea
legislativa por traer un tercero neutral
a la mesa hablar uno de los errores
fundamentales y uno de los orígenes
fundamentales además del de el bajo
índice singularidades de gobierno y los
resultados en materia de política social
a propósito de la pandemia y económica
si tiene que ver con las formas y los
intentos también fallidos de tejer
acuerdos previos a la presentación de la
propuesta con fondo el genial quién
quien podría hacer es ese tercero
neutral que podría entrar en esa mesa de
diálogo si llegara a existir de acuerdo
a lo que usted nos cuenta
el consejo nacional de rectores a través
del programa estado de la nación que
agrupa las universidades públicas del
país fue designado el domingo pasado
como este tercero neutral que iba a
definir la metodología y va a facilitar
el diálogo en aras de conseguir acuerdos
y resolver lo más apremiante en este
momento que la situación económica del
país que es una situación objetiva real
y ante la cual el fondo monetario
internacional está esperando los puestos
de haber después de haber prestado 500
millones de dólares como crédito rápido
el consejo nacional de rectores hoy
anunció que el hecho de que no todas las
organizaciones invitadas a la mesa
quisieran participar daba por
infructuoso este primer esfuerzo
y que se retiraba en ese rol ahora
tendremos que esperar ya a la
presidencia del legislativo anunciaron
que van a seguir con los esfuerzos de
diálogo pero no se vislumbra en el corto
plazo es ese de lineamiento de un
tercero neutral pese a que las
organizaciones ya quieren hacer ahí
puede profundizar están apostando a que
el diálogo se dé en el marco de la
asamblea de trabajadores del banco
popular
la asamblea de trabajadores del el de
los trabajadores
saray cuéntenos desde su organización
desde la asociación que usted lidera qué
propuestas llevan bajo la manga qué
ideas tienen ustedes para proponer que
le sugieren ustedes al gobierno para
empezar a destrabar también un poco
desde el lado de ustedes que sea de
pronto un primer paso para destrabar
esta mesa de diálogo
bueno
para primero tendríamos que conocer muy
bien este por qué habla
eugenia la compañera eugenia si este
foro está iniciando
se formó digámoslo así con las
organizaciones que así no quieren verdad
y nosotros ahorita en este momento no
estamos en el foro si fuimos a todas las
reuniones al alumno que nos invitaron
para participar pero estaba una
situación así como que uno no sabía
exactamente quieren donde iba a pasar
la posibilidad del diálogo
cuando este modo lija está teniendo
bastante participación
nosotros no nos pegamos un lado a otro
esperamos un lado un fondo un espacio de
diálogo que sea objetivo que sea claro
que sea inclusivo y que tome en cuenta a
muchos de los que todavía están
movilizándose de edad entonces presos
eso es un poco lo que es una pregunta
atención en este momento y puede ser te
esperamos en eso y la organización en sí
sí ha hecho propuestas y darle al
gobierno velar porque hay situaciones de
fraude fiscal donde las frustraciones
son así
se señalan que son las que tenemos más
problemas que el gobierno no pierde en
verdad también tenemos una situación de
un sistema tributario donde no faltan
tomar esas medidas progresivas pues la
economía
que está muy muy muy atrasada digamos
así avanzada que son situaciones que
tendríamos que presentar y para eso que
se presentan perdón y para ellos o pues
también hay medidas decir se propone ya
nivel de la propuesta volviendo para
enfrentar esta crisis
sí pero el espacio lo estamos esperando
con esas condiciones que le comenté
anteriormente verdad que incluyan a más
personas que no se limiten que no no sé
si les fijan la cantidad de
participantes
entonces eso lo estamos esperando
eugenia en el marco político que hay en
este momento en costa rica que tanto
margen de negociación tiene el
presidente alvarado en torno a este tema
que tanto puede él jugarse dentro de su
capital político de su desgastada
credibilidad según lo que usted nos
cuenta
teniendo en cuenta valga decirlo ese
descontento que hay entre los ciudadanos
sí bueno el capital político está
definitivamente agotado creo que nuestro
coincidimos en los espacios de análisis
del país y ahí es una figura que ya está
agotada y cuya credibilidad está
ampliamente cuestionada y esto queda de
manifiesto con esta más res esta
propuesta tan reciente para calmar las
dos semanas de manifestaciones no tuvo
efecto a las manifestaciones siguieron
pese al anuncio de este diálogo el día
domingo y hasta el día de hoy el
movimiento es rescate nacional que está
en las calles bloqueando las principales
vías del país y hoy dio una tregua para
efectos de negociar esto no
necesariamente va al ritmo al que
presidente ante el cual el presidente
reaccionó pide algo y la población
responde ante esta situación corresponde
valorar el rol que el presidente
entregue o que negoció con las
fracciones políticas de la asamblea
legislativa una asamblea legislativa muy
dividida pero también donde la fuerza
oficialista es la de las minoritarias
tiene sólo 10 curules de 57
pero están creando y puede echar mano
respecto a pasar o aprobar o valorar
estas reformas sin embargo no debe dejar
de considerar que ya su primera
propuesta puede presentar al país fue
ampliamente rechazada y lo que le
corresponde es construir una nueva
propuesta que nos que no paraliza el
país y continúe por esa vía de el 80 por
ciento de las medidas destinadas a
nuevos impuestos y el otro 20 y un 20
por ciento del gasto público ahora ya le
doy otra vez la palabra quiero
preguntarle eugenia sobre esta propuesta
y esta reforma fiscal que plantearon en
el 2018 negocia también en el 2019 y que
debía entrar en vigor ahora en el 2020
porque ha sido trastocada por esta
coyuntura de la pandemia qué
características tenía y cómo era
entonces ese régimen anterior que tenía
costa rica según entiendo uno de los
puntos importantes era la instauración
de
el impuesto de valor agregado que en
costa rica no estaba
si eso es uno de los cambios más
trascendentales la reforma entró en
vigencia pero parcialmente va cada una
de las disposiciones tenía una
programación distinta y los últimos
atrasos que se hicieron respecto a su
implementación tienen que ver con el
sector construcción y el sector
turístico a propósito de la crisis por
la pandemia la la reforma está
ampliamente implementada lo que
corresponde ahora más bien es valorar si
los efectos de una nueva de esta nueva
propuesta que quiere hacer el gobierno
van a profundizar los descontentos
respecto en que se fundamenta uno de los
puntos clave y aquí vuelvo a la pregunta
que me hiciste respecto a la relación
con los sindicatos y las organizaciones
tiene que ver con que el tercer capítulo
de esa reforma fiscal era una reforma en
términos de empleo público que redujo
los rubros de pago de salarios por
anualidades y otra serie de incentivos
que se estandarizaron y por supuesto
llevó a disgusto de las organizaciones
quienes también se manifestaron ahora
básicamente esta nueva propuesta que
trae el gobierno con el fondo monetario
internacional está relacionada
con el impuesto a las propiedades
también con un impuesto una tasa todo en
un impuesto a las transacciones
bancarias de cualquier tipo desde retiro
de un cajero automático hasta la
creación de un certificado depósito a
plazo y otra serie de medidas que se
califican ampliamente regresivas
entonces corresponderá valorar también a
la luz de los proyectos de ley que ya se
encuentran en la asamblea legislativa
para seguir reduciendo el gasto público
si esta nueva propuesta se va a
equilibrar para satisfacer los intereses
de las fracciones políticas que como les
decía anteriormente está inclinado
ampliamente la reducción del gasto
público será y de acuerdo a lo que vemos
a lo que nos dice usted ya este panorama
político que nos plantea eugenia vemos
muchas discrepancias entre los
sindicatos estos movimientos del cual
usted hace parte y la propuesta del
gobierno pero hay una fuerte necesidad
de dialogo por ambas partes pero hasta
dónde están dispuestos ustedes a llegar
con estas manifestaciones y con este
pedido que le hacen al gobierno
bueno nosotros vamos a seguir adelante
mientras nos manifestemos de manera
pacífica y principalmente porque hay un
reclamo generalizado estos grupos que se
están manifestando no todos son
sindicatos al grupos sociales nada más
comunales esté la gente pueblo que se
llegó a dar cuenta que no se resuelven a
favor verdad todo hace que sea en talla
más import entonces de los dos
los salarios disminuyen dentro arriba ya
que el ingreso familiar también entonces
nosotros seguiremos en la lucha y por
pidiendo principalmente justicia
alimentaria lo que estamos pidiendo es
que el rico pague como rico el poli como
tal
eso es eso es lo que más se le estaba
reclamando y eso es lo que más está
cuanto menos las las medias que está
tomando el gobierno van más en ese
sentido y de no tomar en cuenta también
a los que más tienen porque limonar en
una crisis como descarta o complicada en
medio de una pandemia y una crisis
económica este el aporte tiene que ser
de ambas partes piensa de la parte que
más reclamamos no aquí no hay aporte
sino que la injusticia tanto social como
tributario
se haga anormal las reglas y los
convenios el diálogo todo se tome en
cuenta al sporting claro y ustedes están
en toda la legitimidad democrática como
ciudadanos de reclamarlo exigirlo y
negociarlo con él con el gobierno
eugenia y aprovechando esta coyuntura
del cobi 19 que tanto estas
manifestaciones de verdad responden al
descontento por la coyuntura que tiene
el país por la crisis de la pandemia y
que tanto por simplemente estar en
desacuerdo con estas políticas que está
planteando el gobierno que es
completamente comprensible que haya
quienes hace
y quienes no las acepten
esta es una pregunta fundamental porque
refiere un elemento quieren hacer ahí
acaba de plantear la manifestación es
muy heterogéneo en su composición y en
sus demandas sí es importante tener eso
bien dimensionado tenemos
manifestaciones muy importantes por
ejemplo este proceso inicia en las zonas
periféricas del país en las zonas
costeras con muchísimo más fuerza que en
el área metropolitana y eso habla que no
necesariamente se trata de una sola
petición sino que tenemos lemas
distintos y el lema más repetido es no
más impuestos pero detrás de él no más
impuestos hay agendas muy diversas
respecto a cómo no no sólo cómo resolver
sino a cómo es sustituir ese ingreso y
sacrificarlo en términos de gasto
entonces real realmente el reto en
términos de diálogo del gobierno es
clave acá quiero por ejemplo dar el
ejemplo d
los transportistas manifestándose al
mismo tiempo que el sector pesquero al
mismo tiempo que agricultores campesinos
y al mismo tiempo que otro tipo de
organizaciones que tienen una agenda
política y de incidencia muchísimo más
clara entonces no tenemos que
considerarlo como un solo movimiento
sino como el conjunto de una serie de
disgustos y demandas estructurales que
no han sido atendidas y que va a
demandar un diálogo en al menos tres
niveles un diálogo en lo territorial y
en las necesidades más inmediatas de
sectores que llevan muchísimo tiempo
reclamando un diálogo respecto a la
deposición de los movimientos que
bloquean las vías públicas y dificultan
muchísimo la convivencia y una tercera
línea que tiene que ver con el fondo
monetario internacional pero no caigamos
en creer esto se trata solamente de la
agenda que se propuso el fondo monetario
internacional sino que es un acumulado
inclusive de otros proyectos en
corriente legislativa que se sostienen
como la reforma integral al empleo
público
disgusta y genera estás desconfianza
entre los de esa negociación con el
fondo fue el detonante de una serie de
acumulación de temas de diferentes
sectores ya usted no lo explicaba
eugenia me quedan poco más de dos
minutos para la conclusión del programa
saray no tenemos la bola de cristal para
saber qué va a pasar en las próximas
semanas en este país centroamericano
pero desde su perspectiva como cree que
van a terminar estas negociaciones estos
posibles encuentros esta posible mesa de
diálogo que podría tener lugar si hay
una retoma aquí de las conversaciones
bueno esta costa rica es un país de paz
en este momento y con los gobiernos con
los colonos anteriores y este y la gente
se cansó también de medidas que no nos
consideraban a ello y desde entonces es
complicado nosotros creemos en el
diálogo verdad creemos en la paz y eso
es muy importante no estamos haciendo
muchos esfuerzos para que sucediese
llevar a cabo eso lo que más pedimos
delante se puede lograr pero aquí lo más
importante como le decía antes es que
sean medidas tomadas con justicia con
igualdad para todos en cuáles
condiciones no pueden ser que unos
paguen más y otros que que tienen más no
saben o paguen menos entonces eso de la
esperanza de nosotros para no 500
justicia y diálogo me quedo con esas dos
palabras ahora y eugenia su conclusión
de lo que puede suceder a futuro
gracias no me gusta sacar la bola de
cristal pero creo que estamos en
momentos en que cada segundo y cada
decisión afecta trascendentalmente el
futuro de nuestro país y sobre todo
pensando en restaurar el orden público y
particularmente retomar las vías del
diálogo que han sido abandonadas en este
momento una vez caído este primer
esfuerzo de diálogo corresponde valorar
cuál es la contrapropuesta que hará el
gobierno y cómo va a lograr de alguna
manera que los sectores le respondan a
su propuesta de diálogo tal vez a través
de una nueva metodología un nuevo
interlocutor o la explicación de nuevas
formas y nuevas alternativas respecto a
que llevar a la mesa al fondo monetario
internacional- que tampoco se ha
cuestionado que no se vaya a ir verdad
al fondo pues eugenia ya se hará y
muchas gracias por habernos puesto en
contexto a la audiencia de france 24 en
diferentes rincones del continente
americano gracias por explicarnos y
poner sobre la mesa sus puntos de vista
entorno
a esta coyuntura que está viviendo a
costa rica muchas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros aquí en france24
pura vida para las dos allí en san jose
y a ustedes muchas gracias también por
haber estado hoy en el debate pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios todas sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
los invito para que sigan con nuestra
programación
[Música]